all right switching gears here to talk
about the weather great for great
weather outside i should say yeah but we
miss when ted's not in studio but we
know he's got to be on some rides out
there at boca park ted have you met a
lot of nice people
yeah there's a lot of people out here
kirsten uh and it's getting packed as we
speak so we want to let you know a
little bit more about this pumpkin patch
we're going to bring in mike thomas
first of all mike thomas i want to thank
you for having the easiest name in the
world so we can pronounce that easy and
please take the mask off oh i'm just
going to i'm kept kidding i'm kidding
with halloweentown thanks for having us
here tell us i mean this is huge i drive
by this all the time but what can we
find in here that everybody can do
there's something for everybody there's
young rides for the young kids there's
games that the adults can remember when
they were children there's cotton candy
there's carnival fair and food there's
great opportunities for pictures and
it's probably the single best selection
of pumpkins in las vegas i'll agree on
that and this isn't the only location
how many locations are there because
there's people all around the valley
watching us right now absolutely we've
got another location at rainbow and warm
springs and then another one at
silverado ranch and las vegas boulevard
that's great now which one has the
margaritas
that one okay but we also have to
village across the street so that works
too michael thank you so much i
appreciate it we'll see you again uh in
the five o'clock hour right thank you
sir appreciate it all right let's take a
look right now at our forecast first we
begin with the almanac it was a warm day
today not reaching our full potential
just yet because our high probably going
to be in the low 80s again
but we'll wait and see what the national
weather service says the official high
will be
so with that said let's go to our
southwest radar right now radar not
showing anything here in the desert
southwest but if you look way up the
pacific northwest you can see some of
those showers there those clouds also
will increase not today but they will
increase tomorrow where we do anticipate
those clouds later on in the afternoon
moving on to your daily wind forecast
the reason i want to show you this
because i want to show you halloween
specifically so winds tomorrow not so
bad now they will pick up for halloween
and i've been telling you about this all
week the past week that halloween will
have some wind now we will see some
breezes specifically in the afternoon
and then it will start to die off or the
evening so prepare some winds especially
for those of you that live in the
southwest part of the valley
and then some light breezes also on
monday hey buddy how are you buddy we'll
get to you in a second all right your
halloween forecast mild and spooky we'll
leave it right here nice and evening
temperatures will be in the high mid 70s
to high 60s
coming up though i'll show you an
hour-by-hour look of what to expect for
this evening hey i want to introduce you
to captain america hey hey captain
america
hey buddy
hi jj
we're going to get some tissues
all right we'll have more in your
forecast coming up i got a lot to talk
about as far as this goes and how your
halloween looks that's all straight
ahead in your most accurate forecast in
just a couple minutes reporting live at
the boca park halloween town ted
florendo live local
now
all right ted maybe he'll be dressed up
for the next hit captain america making
an appearance cute it is a fun weekend
ahead for families